c'était un coup de gueule un ras-le-bol
plus je
ça arrive régulièrement ils ont pas peur
de la justice ceux qui font ça et se
sentent intouchables bien souvent ils
sont intouchables donc tu t'es dit moi
je vais les afficher voilà on se dit on
va essayer de les faire culpabiliser un
peu de honte pour eux et pour nous ça
portait ses fruits alors dis-nous
pourquoi voilà ça c'est important ça de
nous dire qu'est-ce que ça porte mais en
fait on a mis ça on savait qu'on allait
faire un petit buzz mais localement
voilà ça a pris beaucoup vous n'avez pas
de solution
la solution c'est malheureusement les
voleurs c'est des entreprises bien à
part on peut prendre les grands magasins
avec des vigiles une équipe de
vidéosurveillance
et même ils a malgré ça ils arrivent
c'est pas les vols ça vous coûte combien
tous les mois
énormément mais on va dire
une centaine d'euros pour nous on va
prendre un petit commerce donc tous les
mois ça devient une histoire de 300
euros quand même et sur une année
complète moi je trouve c'est malheureux
que les magasins doivent compter dans
leur dans leur bilan des vols des pertes
c'est un peu malheureux donc est-ce que
les clients ils approuvent votre
démarche ah oui on était soutenu
des gens vous soutiennent beaucoup de
clients qui viennent nous féliciter nous
soutenir après on sait qu'on est
complètement dans l'illégalité tout
comme les voleurs du coup vous allez
prendre vous allez prendre une amende
pour l'instant qu'il y a pas de plainte
déposer contre nous non d'accord il
faudrait que les voleurs déposent une
plante contre les voleurs
[Rires]
je vous le dis je vais lire un truc tout
à l'heure là dans un instant vous allez
voir que c'est que c'est complètement
fou comme dit ça c'est réglé donc je on
a retiré notre plainte parce qu'on est
correct on veut pas être dans le même
cadre que on reste correct on a retiré
la plainte on a retiré nos images on a
récupéré nos articles
on espère que ça servir aux autres de
leçons et voilà et ça a porté ses fruits
ça a porté ses fruits et deux jours
après ceux qui nous ont volé ils nous
ont ramené les articles incroyables ah
ouais sans gêne un culottes ou ça c'est
fou quoi les mecs deux jours après ils
sont nuls ils ont dit ouais bon allez on
oublie tous les a vu venir avec les deux
articles qu'ils ont volés nous disant on
pensait que c'est elle qui a payé moi je
pensais que c'était
sur les vidéos on voyait bien que
c'était dissimulé caché sous la voiture
et bien sûr alors on a coupé court on a
dit ok c'est bon merci revenez plus
jamais et voilà alors Mathieu Totet toi
tu étais pour ce genre de pas évidemment
parce que ce qui est très grave c'est
toujours pareil c'est que tout est fait
pour les délinquants avec pour les gens
honnêtes et deux choses la première dans
les grands magasins quand quelqu'un se
fait arrêter parce qu'il a volé donc
déjà 6 fait arrêter parce que souvent il
passe mais si c'est arrêté tout ce qu'on
lui demande c'est de payer ce qu'il
avait volé en général la police
intervient pas donc il n'a aucun risque
autant tenté et la deuxième chose qu'il
faut savoir c'est que aujourd'hui les
prix augmentent au magasin parce que
justement ils font payer la perte due au
vol et du coup ils augmentent un peu les
prix donc les gens honnêtes payent plus
cher parce que les gens qui veulent
c'est c'est aberrant et encore une fois
on dit toujours la même chose ceux qui
veulent ne risquent absolument rien
pourquoi ne ferait-il pas donc
finalement moi je veux même pas aux gens
qui sont malades j'en veux à la justice
de rien faire donc évidemment qu'il faut
il faut en arriver là c'est à dire qu'il
faut encore on en arrive au fait que
c'est à nous et nous-mêmes de faire
juste pardon que ce soit nous de faire
la justice bah en tout cas c'est quelle
société que tu proposes donc une société
il approuvé que ça fonctionnait ils sont
revenus pardon pour une fois quelque
chose fonctionne
normalement pardon voilà ça c'est un cas
isolé oui d'accord mais normalement vous
aviez effectivement les vidéos je
comprends tout à fait hein vous allez
voir et je comprends non mais je
comprends le désarroi de Monsieur et je
comprends même la lassitude parce que de
devoir régulièrement
mais mais vous aviez ces vidéos vous les
donnez à la justice et puis bien sûr
mais malheureusement
abonnez les vidéos vous lui donnez à la
justice déjà à qui tu vas la donner à la
justice c'est qui la justice toi
tu vas aller voir un policier il va dire
alors qu'est-ce qui va se passer vous
l'avez déjà fait ça ok bien sûr elle est
dans le monde est dans mon arrivée
alors effectivement la justice prend du
temps effectivement ça fonctionne pas
on dit pas de se faire justice soi-même
d'accord et cetera mais ça je trouve que
c'est un moyen limite bien sûr malin
c'est malin à la limite après voilà
après on ce qu'on veut mais Valérie
Bénaïm allez au commissariat vous y avez
déjà été au commissariat on y va
régulièrement alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé ben ils prennent notre plainte oui
ils font leur boulot
de téléphone nous on en veut venir la
justice ni à la police c'était je pense
qu'ils ont d'autres chats fouetter des
cas plus grave
c'est sans suite toujours pour les trucs
comme ça tu crois qu'ils vont faire quoi
il est policiers les pauvres ils ont du
travail de fou mais ils ont 50 000 trucs
à faire je crois qu'ils vont faire quoi
donc toi qui est pas d'accord là
pourquoi moi je comprends la tentation
de Nicolas parce que il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des vrais mafia il
y a même des voleurs qui mettent des
vêtements en aluminium pour que ça sonne
pas à la sortie donc je comprends la
tentation de les dénoncer mais vous ne
pouvez pas faire ça Nicolas parce que
c'est vraiment le moral mais non mais
c'est ok mais vous pouvez pas répondre à
quelque chose d'illégal ou d'un moral
par la même chose c'est de la délation
en fait non mais tu proposes
à propos soin oppose vous allez porter
plainte monsieur vous allez porter
plaindre tu proposes comme Valérie
Bénaïm mais la police la police agit il
y a eu plein de mafia à arrêter
démantelé 120 fois récidiviste la police
arrive et la justice les sanctionne si
on commence à dénoncer chacun celui qui
vole à afficher sur les réseaux sociaux
là je vends les magasins possibles c'est
depuis les lois tobirates
les mafia c'est les mecs vous rigolez
c'est des matières des supers
[Rires]
non mais qu'est-ce qu'il raconte
mais eh mais tu dis que des conneries
c'est bon
ok de ces voleurs qui eux n'ont aucune
pitié quand ils voient ils en ont rien à
[ __ ] monsieur il a raison de de se
venger comme ça il est victime d'une
profonde injustice chaque semaine il y a
des personnes qui vole des centaines
voire des milliers d'euros dans des plus
grands commerces et il se passe rien qui
me dit je travaille dans une grande
surface tiens Valérie Benaim et Gilles
Verdez les citoyens euh à chaque fois
que les gendarmes viennent saisir des
vidéos pour des vols il ne se passe
absolument rien les gendarmes font leur
travail mais derrière il se passe rien
il repart et les voleurs finissent même
pas revenir pour revoler voilà merci
non seulement c'est trop long et en plus
il ne se passe rien donc vous avez
raison de faire ça ne serait-ce que
d'une pour manifester votre
mécontentement et en plus ça fait
avancer les choses puisque ça stoppe le
vol ça les empêche de récidiver donc
s'il faut que vous enfreignez la loi
pour arriver à faire ça tant mieux et
c'est que la loi est mal faite non mais
c'est pas parce que ça c'est bien passé
une fois qu'on doit l'établir en règle
monsieur pardon moi je comprends votre
exaspération et c'est un fléau pour
votre commerce et malgré tout ça doit
pas servir de jurisprudence parce que ça
veut dire quoi alors ça veut dire qu'on
des vidéos et on croit encore comme
l'affaire de Roanne reconnaître le gars
et finalement c'est pas le gars ou c'est
pas la peine
c'est pas le gars moi vous êtes vous
connaissez mieux les enquêtes non
si jamais c'est pas la personne on peut
à ce moment-là
comparable mais si là par exemple on
tabasse une personne qui n'est pas
responsable du vol parce qu'elle lui
ressemble ou alors ça veut dire quoi la
prochaine étape derrière le comptoir il
y aura un flingue et le commerçant la
prochaine fois il fait encore quelqu'un
qui va voler
incomparable mais en fait le problème
c'est que à partir du moment même si la
justice est laxiste même si à mon avis
faut que les lois changent on ne peut
pas malgré tout se substituer un système
de vols c'est que des vols
c'est quoi alors il fait quoi le donneur
de leçon vous faites mais c'est pas une
question de donner raison
mais vous allez vous ouvrez beaucoup vos
jambes
les leçons
je vais peut-être pas les bonnes choses
là c'est bon
je suis dégoûté que les gens il y a des
gens qui payent qui sont en galère quand
même leurs aliments et il y en a
d'autres qui volent moi je suis dégoûté
incroyable par rapport à celui qui la
nana qui est avec ses gamins qui se
saignent et qui passe en caisse par
rapport à l'autre qui a volé là-dessus
je vous suis là-dessus je suis d'accord
avec vous et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
changer les lois et faire passer des
messages quand on en ce moment on en a
après la justice mais c'est tout un
système qu'il faut revoir parce que ça
c'est pas normal non plus maintenant sur
la délation comme a dit Géraldine ça
s'est passé bien pour vous vous êtes
peut-être grand vous êtes peut-être
costaud ça s'est passé bien par rapport
aux gens qui vous envolaient si demain
tu commences à filmer tous les gens qui
s'amusent à voler j'ai peur que ça fasse
des dégâts ça fasse l'effet inverse j'ai
peur que les gens reviennent pour régler
des comptes à plusieurs ça dépend une
fois de plus sous l'endroit où tu es ça
dépend l'endroit où tu as et moi j'ai
mis un nom j'ai mis un nom parce que je
ne serai jamais pour la délation c'est
pas possible pour faire bouffer les
choses
quand le mec a volé là il faut que quand
le mec a le vol il faut pas justement ok
moi j'ai eu un cas en télévision il y a
Michel qui avait volé l'orange
[Applaudissements]
il a une vidéo il voit quelqu'un qui a
volé quelque chose en quoi c'est un
problème de montrer son visage pour se
protéger
c'est peut-être illégal mais ce monsieur
ça fait des années qu'il a un problème
on fait jamais rien bien sûr alors tu
vas me dire oui alors si on met tout le
monde ils vont suivre
non mais moi honnêtement je comprends
très bien le qui qui le fasse et je leur
ai fait aussi si on ne fait jamais alors
si un jour attention il achète un sweat
à capuche à même suite à capuche qu'un
mec qui a volé qu'on reconnaît pas bien
il va repartir français
les mec il a affiché il les a repéré il
les a vu lui oh mais il y a jamais
banquette
véritablement la police ou pas
pardon
vous êtes insupportable Mathieu Dieu
sait si vraiment tout le respect que
j'ai pour la police mais je vais te dire
moi j'ai été cambriolé ils sont venus
ils ont regardé s'il y avait deux trois
empreintes je suis allé au commissariat
je dirais pas lequel je suis arrivé
est-ce qu'on va retrouver les trucs qui
m'ont dit non je dis pourquoi parce
qu'il m'a dit on ne changera pas voilà
ce qui m'a dit je te jure que c'est vrai
ils peuvent pas ils ont pas les moyens
de choses à [ __ ] que les chercher ils
ont pas les moyens peuvent pas faire ça
donc il y aura pas d'enquête pour
effectivement deux boîtes de conserve et
pour ce monsieur qui a perdu 100 €, il y
aura pas donc ce qu'il faut faire en
sorte c'est qu'il n'y ait plus de vol
pour toute façon ne peut pas les cours
alors Kelly
c'est pour moi s'il a agi de manière
pacifique et le jour où le gouvernement
se rendra compte que les gens sont
obligés de se débrouiller tout seul et
d'agir tout seul peut-être que là il se
diront bon on va peut-être bouger parce
que là c'est les gens commencent à faire
un petit peu la guerre tout seul ils
vont se dire bon bah là faut qu'on
arrange les choses parce que ça peut
plus durer tout simplement
le jour où il voit ils vont revenir à 5
parce que je veux dire après je me tais
le jour ils vont revenir à 5 sur lui
avec des barres de fer qui finira dans
un fauteuil roulant parce qu'il a parce
qu'on lui a pris deux boîtes de conserve
on verra comment vous allez parler mais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire attention
on va flipper et va voir que les gens se
débrouillent tout seul ils vont
peut-être agir la vie de Daniel qui met
non je suis étonné oui moi aussi me de
moi-même parce que je n'arrive pas à
m'étonner parce que c'est illégal mais
je suis à 120 ans exactement mais ça y
est ça y est on y est on est au Far West
et c'est ça qui me fait peur on sait pas
quoi
les photos excusez-moi c'est ça et et
Monsieur Je ne vous blâme absolument pas
parce que je mets non parce que c'est
illégal mais voilà vous avez tout à fait
raison et j'espère vraiment que le
gouvernement va prendre conscience de ça
parce que là on y est on est en plein
dans le Far West et malheureusement vous
vous êtes obligé de faire ça et j'en ai
marre aussi qu'on protège toujours les
bourreaux et pas les victimes donc il y
a pas de raison
de de ceux qui veulent moi je trouve ça
très bien sauf que j'ai du mal à mettre
oui parce que c'est illégal et que voilà
un vieux fond d'éducation non n'empêche
très intéressant gros Cyril non mais
Cyril il faut dire aussi qu'il risque
gros Nicolas c'est ça qui est c'est 3
ans 3 ans de prison 45000 euros d'amende
et même un an de plus pour atteinte à la
vie privée parce que c'est une
utilisation détournée de la vidéo
surveillance qui est réservé à
quelques-uns qui ont le droit de la
regarder et on n'a pas le droit de la
diffuser moi je mets aussi non pour vous
protéger vous risquez
trois ans avec mes 45 minutes
avec tout ce qu'on voit passer sur ce
plateau des gens qui sont même pas
condamnés on vend des choses abominable
tu nous dis sur ce plateau sérieusement
qui risque trois ans
pour lui c'est pas du tout
ouais t'as raison
on l'a fait on le sait hein si on l'a
fait c'est qu'on est prêt à prendre le
risque c'est qu'on veut faire bouger les
choses en fait comment vous avez pris la
décision vous êtes dit quoi sur un coup
de tête c'est pas vous en avez on a vu
ça vous étiez vénère on a on a dit on va
porter plainte comme d'habitude on m'a
dit mais il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose parce que ça devient de pire en
pire on laisse passer une fois c'est le
même genre reviendront une deuxième fois
une troisième fois vont dire dans leur
entourage ils vont venir je sais pas
combien c'est fini après c'est un cercle
sans fin c'est donc c'était on dit on va
essayer de mettre un stop à ça faire
bouger les choses après on est conscient
de tout le risque qu'on prend mais si on
l'a fait c'est qu'on est conscient et
qu'on accepte de les sanctions on veut
faire bouger les choses
et maintenant encore plus à l'échelle
nationale même parce que vous voudrez
bien ici tous les commerçants feront ça
ferait ça il y aurait la justice peut
pas s'occuper de tous ces cas-là donc je
peux dire que les lois sont pas
appliquées c'est que les personnes
effectivement qui ont volé non rien et
que ce monsieur qui a fait quelque chose
illégal n'aura rien non plus donc de
toute façon quel que soit le cas
personne sera condamné voilà si on peut
les retenir donc on fait quoi alors
Mathieu pour toi c'est quoi c'est quoi
vos solutions ici allez-y là parce que
les donneurs de le sont là
avec Monsieur il faut faire en sorte que
la peur change de camp que les gens qui
volent et véritablement peur même pour
la réintégrité il faut qu'à un moment
les choses s'arrêtent et encore une fois
les seuls le seul moyen pour l'instant
ce sont ces moyens là c'est à dire des
gens qui essaient de faire des choses
par eux-mêmes puisque la loi ne peut
rien pour eux vraiment des sursis faut
mettre de l'amande et du sursis c'est
très grave de voler c'est ce qu'on a dit
tout à l'heure il y en a qui vont se
prendre la tête c'est ça qu'on est en
train d'expliquer le problème qu'on a
avec la justice depuis un certain temps
depuis des semaines qui sont tout revoir
un moment donné il faut arrêter les
conneries il faut arrêter que la France
elle part en sucette lui en attendant il
reste il reste tranquille en attendant
et je sais pas si elle va changer mais
tu peux pas il faudrait mettre des trois
mois de sursis des des amendes à ces
gens là pour qu'ils disent ça sert plus
rien de voler dans les magasins il y a
plus à perdre d'aller voler dans un
magasin que de pas y aller mais de
filmer les gens moi j'ai peur moi ça me
fait peur de filmer les gens si on vous
vole trois fois en une semaine vous
personnellement vous ferez quoi ok
ils font comment les propositions ont
commencé malheureux ce qui est
malheureux quand tu te fais voler
plusieurs fois ce qui est malheureux
c'est qu'il faut que tu mettes un vigile
ce qui est malheureux faut que tu mettes
un portique mais ça coûte beaucoup
d'oseille c'est que ça coûte même avec
ça ils veulent d'accord avec ça avec ça
ils veulent peut-être un peu moins si
ton vigile est efficace ils veulent
peut-être un peu moins après c'est
depuis la nuit des temps qu'on voit le
supermarchés
apparemment il aimait bien le
théâtre
c'est bon alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez rajouter on ne peut c'est quoi ta
solution
toi tu donnes des leçons surtout mais
non en fait aucune opinion
poulet dans le Burger King
on bloque les autres roues on se fait
voler on se fait voler tranquille on
fait un
[Musique]
mais toi toi j'espère que jamais
j'espère que jamais tu seras élu ou
quelque part merci catastrophe c'est
gentil d'amitié réduisant
il était horrible tu es horrible tu es
horrible tu es tout ce qu'il faut pas
faire en fait tu es toujours à côté de
la plaque je suis légaliste
on peut pas dire que la police et la
gendarmerie ne font rien en France qui a
dit ça c'est encore une fois tu dis ça
mais tu as des grandes oreilles mais tu
écoutes rien c'est ça ton problème
on a dit justement la gendarmerie et la
police il a dit lui-même ils font leur
boulot ils vont prendre la plainte mais
tu crois vraiment qu'ils ont que ça à
[ __ ] tu as vu tout le travail qu'ils
ont la police et la gendarmerie tu crois
à moi qui vont aller chercher de garde
ton voler des rochers Suchard non mais
tu sais tu crois vraiment vous dire on
est sur un démantèlement de rocher
Suchard là où il est pas dispo c'est la
mafia des Balisto non mais c'est
arrête de dire des conneries ils ont pas
que ça à [ __ ] la police
s'il vous plaît merci merci Aubry là
merci merci au gruyère c'est bon euh non
mais je te le dis je te le dis le gaz
qui est en train de dire c'est qui il a
eu cette idée c'est tout il s'est dit ça
il s'est dit que ça allait marcher après
on dit pas que c'est bien on dit pas que
c'est pas bien c'est juste que les gars
sont excellent et que la police et la
gendarmerie les pauvres gages je te dis
non pas que ça à [ __ ] et on le sait il
a pas dit qu'il faisait pas leur travail
Mathieu embout il a juste dit qu'ils
avaient pas que ça [ __ ] il fera
faillite avant voilà bah si il risque de
faire pareil
bien sûr que j'espère qu'il fera pas
failli échouer tout le meilleur à
Nicolas arrêter et Cyril en ce moment
c'est un sujet national c'est c'est à
Forbach c'était les spectateurs tiens
les donneurs de leçons là Martine Aubry
Martin merci bravo
bravo après on est passé bien on n'est
pas accélère mais le gars est excédé
après moi je trouve que c'est une
solution pacifique à la limite tu vois
ou pas bon Nicolas tu nous diras si
voilà c'est ça se passe bien pour toi
j'espère merci d'être venu Merci à VOUS
Nico et voilà si je peux te donner un
conseil sinon tu prends vigile Valérie
Benaim et Gilles Verdenne on va voir tu
auras plus aucun problème